so a few days ago I received an email
from a lady called Astrid mcdougal
there's there's a person on the roof
okay right there's a person on the roof
over there can you see him oh he's gone
behind a chimney hold on wait for mu
he'll come back he didn't come back I
don't know where he's gone but I swear
there was a person on the roof I don't
know what he's doing there but that
confused me um so a few days ago I
received an email from a lady called
Astrid mcdougal which is a fun name to
say and basically in the email she said
um Charlie your hair is cool please
don't shave it off so for Astrid and for
everyone who doesn't know already I have
kind of already shaved my hair off tada
I'm not gonna deny the fact that a lot
of people were against the idea of me
shaving my hair off but since I have
shaved it off I've received numerous
compliments about the shape of my head
and lots of people in real life have
still been calling me cutie pie and
cutie face so my looks apparently
according to popular opinion are still
intact fortunately it turns out that the
most important part of my appearance was
not my hair but is apparently my face
and my face is still present on my body
so we're all good basically good news
all round what's also good news and what
it's probably better news than the fact
that my face is still quite nice is the
fact that according to my calculator we
raised five thousand one hundred and
sixty seven pounds and fifty nine pence
for cancer research UK which is amazing
thank you so much for everyone I came
and then to everyone who donated this is
money that will help our cancer people
which is good news I didn't say this in
the last video that I made but the
reason I decided to raise money for
cancer research UK in particular is
because last year on the day after my
birthday my gran died of cancer I'm
saying cancer is close to my heart in
that respect so yeah thank you to
everyone who donated your money is gonna
go far thank you thank you thank you
figure thank you what I do want to tell
you is the fact that the Just Giving
page that we were using just giving calm
/blog TV birthday is still open it's
still available for donations so if you
didn't get a chance to sponsor me before
you still can even though the word
sponsor really doesn't mean much seeing
as I've already shaved it off but you
didn't get a chance
before you still can links in the
sidebar they give it a little lower in
other news you might have noticed the
fact that the calculator I was using
previously isn't in fact a real
calculator but is actually an iPhone
because I am an Apple fanboy
and I if it wasn't for my darling
MacBook then I would definitely say that
this is the greatest thing that I have
ever purchased in my life ever I am in
love with this phone
I'm also rubbing my nickel apparently
while I say I'm in love with this phone
that's not good and having a new phone
for me just generally is an amazing
luxury because the phone I've been using
previously is this which is missing a
key and the zero key is broken I've used
this phone for way too long so just to
have a new thing that works and lets me
call people it's good oh yeah
new phone whoo my mum wanted to be in
the video so I'm here she is okay as
well as getting an iPhone I kind of also
went to New York last week which was
insane here is a speedy photo montage
speedy photo montage it's speedy photo
montage basically there's this guy
called John Green who writes books the
most recent of which being Paper Towns
which I've read and is good and the
launch party for his new book Paper
Towns was in New York and my friend Alex
was like I want to go to that launch
party do you want to come with me and I
said I don't have enough money to get to
that launch party and he said he'd pay
for me and I said and then he said I
booked the tickets now we have to go and
then two days later we were in New York
so yeah that's why we went to New York
because of this book so you should
probably buy this book it's funny
actually because the Queen of England
recently came to Google headquarters and
I was invited to go to Google
headquarters to meet the Queen of
England but instead of meeting the Queen
I decided to meet John Green I am gonna
go now but just quickly before I leave I
do want to say the money that I raised
for cancer research UK did go to cancer
research UK
I did not spend that money on trips to
New York and iPhones I promise okay
I did I knew you might be thinking that
but I promise the money went to charity
not on gifts and holidays for me